M
VENEZUELA.
WE WILL BRING YOU THERE.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT OVERSEAS WITH
AN ESCALATION AND TENSION IN
JERUSALEM.
A HEAVY ROCKET BARRAGE FIRED
FROM GAZA INTO SOUTHERN ISRAEL
WITHIN THE PAST TWO HOURS SO FAR
BEING TAKEN OUT OF THE SKIES BY
THE ISRAELI MISSILE DEFENSE
SYSTEM KNOWN AS THE IRON DOME.
ATTACK AND COUNTER ATTACK AND
PALESTINIAN DEATH TOLLS RISING
TONIGHT.
FOREIGN CORRESPONDENT TREY
YINGST HAS BEEN IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE FIGHTING ALL DAY.
GOOD EVENING, TREY.
>> BRET, GOOD EVENING, THOSE
ROCKETS CONTINUE TO BE FIRED
INTO SOUTHERN ISRAEL AT THIS
MOMENT.
ALL ALONG THE GAZA STRIP.
OVERHEAD WE CAN HEAR ISRAELI
DRONES AND FIGHTER JETS.
ISRAEL IS PREPARING THEIR
RETALIATION AGAINST THE FACTIONS
THERE.
HERE'S WHAT LED UP TO THE EVENTS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
EXPLOSIONS AND SMOKE FILL THE
MOSQUE.
EARLY THIS MORNING ONE OF THE
WORLD'S HOLIEST SITES ERUPTED.
300 PALESTINIANS WERE INJURED AS
ISRAELI POLICE STORMED THE
COMPOUND.
>> THEY ARE ATTACKING HUMAN
BEINGS.
ATTACKING THE HOLY PLACES.
IT'S AGAINST ALL INTERNATIONAL
HUMAN LAWS.
THESE BARBARIANS AGGRESSIVE
ATTACKS ON OUR HOLY PLACES.
>> SHEIKH OMAR SAID RECENT
UNREST IS DIRECTLY LINKED BY
DECISIONS OF ISRAEL TRYING TO
EVICT PALESTINIAN FAMILIES FROM
THEIR HOMES.
MONDAY MARKED JERUSALEM DAY.
A NATIONAL HOLIDAY THAT
COMMEMORATES ISRAEL TAKING OVER
EAST JERUSALEM IN 1967.
THE CITY WAS ALSO THE FIRST
TARGET FOR FACTIONS INSIDE GAZA
WHO THIS EVENING FIRED SIX
ROCKETS TOWARDS IT.
THE BARRAGE WAS THE FIRST OF
MORE THAN A HUNDRED ROCKETS
FIRED BY ISRAEL AND JIHAD WHO
SAY THEY WILL SUPPORT
PALESTINIAN RESISTANCE AT ALL
COST.
>> ROCKET FIRE IS CONTINUING
FROM THE GAZA STRIP.
THERE IS A WARNING GOING OFF
RIGHT NOW.
AS YOU CAN HEAR ISRAEL'S MISSILE
DEFENSE SYSTEM THE IRON DOME
TRYING TO INTERCEPT THESE ROUNDS
BEING FIRED FROM GAZA.
THAT'S THE EXPLOSION RIGHT THERE
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
LIFE AND DEATH FOR MANY OF THESE
CIVILIANS LIVING ALONG THE
BORDER.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE HERE INSIDE
BOMB SHELTER.
YOU CAN SEE FAMILIES ARE JUST
TRYING TO GET INTO THIS SHELTER.
LET US GET OUT OF THE WAY HERE.
THIS IS WHAT SOUTHERN ISRAEL HAS
BEEN DEALING WITH ALL NIGHT.
OFF IN THE DISTANCE CAN YOU HEAR
MORE SIRENS.
THESE ROUNDS ARE COMING IN
CONTINUOUSLY.
>> WE WILL NOT TOLERATE HARM TO
OUR TERRITORY, TO OUR CAPITOL,
TO OUR CITIZENS OR TO OUR
SOLDIERS.
HE WHO ATTACKS US WILL PAY A
HEAVY PRICE.
>> BENJAMIN NETANYAHU STARTING
TO RING TRUE ACROSS GAZA.
AT LEAST 20 PEOPLE ARE DEAD FROM
ISRAELI RETALIATION.
SOME OF THEM ARE CHILDREN.
HOW DOES THIS ALL END?
THAT'S THE BIG QUESTION HERE
TONIGHT.
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY FOR AN
EGYPTIAN LED CEASE-FIRE
NEGOTIATION BUT THAT NEGOTIATION
COULD TAKE DAYS.